[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm pbht here and
welcome to autofocus episode 2 so today
we're gonna look at apple carplay and
i've heard of it a little bit but I've
never actually tried it Tesla's don't
have it so today we got a car that does
have it that we can explore so this is
the 2018 lamborghini aventador s but
honestly the real reason this car did
catch my attention was because it has
apple carplay I swear it seems like most
in cardassia's no matter what the car
are pretty bad at navigation whatever
they do so it feels like apple carplay
and android auto are the two best
chances new cars have at connecting to
your smartphone and working easily and
functionally in a way that people
actually use so the best connection most
people now have to their cars is just
bluetooth when they get in so they get
in the car it automatically connects to
bluetooth and then you get your music
and maybe your phone calls right with
Android auto or apple carplay you get a
whole operating system as soon as you
get in your car so with this you get in
you plug in your iPhone lights up and
you get carplay so you get Apple Maps
you get Siri all the time you get text
messages you get stuff that you're used
to having on your phone so let's do that
so you start with the normal Lamborghini
UI in the car which I gotta say is
pretty badass looking inside all this
carbon-fiber you control it with this
knob in the middle you press in to
select and they can do all kinds of
things like navigate somewhere or toggle
things inside or outside the car you
plug in your iPhone though you can give
it a second to recognize everything and
then boom carplay comes to life
immediately now you're controlling the
iPhone through the UI of the car this is
way better than Lamborghinis UI instead
of spinning a dial and trying to like
type in an address then navigate through
an on-screen keyboard and all that kind
of stuff you just use your phone's
navigation system it's not your
fingertips or with voice control now
that is still Apple maps and Siri but
it's better than before so you still
have all the same functionality you're
used to and basically the idea is you
get to do as much as possible hands-free
so you can focus on driving assuming
you'd probably want to do some driving
in a car like this in fact let's drive
to another location
so yeah you'll notice a lot of
similarities between carplay UI and the
iPhones homescreen obviously that's the
idea you're supposed to feel at home
like you never left your phone behind so
that's what you're familiar with you get
the home button in the bottom left
corner above that you got the time in
the most recent apps you've opened and
then the main section is the layout of
all the Apple apps the default ones
first and then the third-party ones that
are actually on my iPhone that are
compatible with carplay so anything
that's on the iPhone that's compatible
will show up here and then I can move
these around wherever I want I can add
pages if there's more apps add apps to
my phone and just put them however I
want it's pretty useful all right new
location
[Music]
so there's a couple of third-party apps
on my phone I got pocket casts and
Spotify and these both also work with
car plates so when I open them they open
the car play version on the cars display
and then there's this whole list on
Apple's site of apps that are compatible
that will also show up in car play if
you open them it's not the longest list
I'd actually but probably say Android
auto has a longer list of compatible
apps in the Play Store but there's still
some pretty good apps here and then not
only that it's a one to one connection
with the phone so if I have it open on
the phone it opens in the dashboard as
well other apps that aren't compatible
won't do anything on the car screen
they'll just open on the phone screen
but it's cool that it's actually this
responsive and then of course probably
the most useful functionality in a car
voice control in this case it is Siri
and that can be for responding to text
messages it doesn't show the text of
what you say to respond on the screen
which is a bummer I wish it did but
basically it reads your responses back
to you and asks you if you want to send
it and then you can send it off so how
much you use this will basically just
depend on how much you trust series
voice recognition oh and by the way
driving an Aventador is incredible when
granted I only had a day and a half with
it and you can only learn so much about
a car just by spending that little time
but I have plenty of observations about
this ridiculous half million-dollar
supercar number one this car is low
everything about it is super low the
roof line is like forehead level so if
you want to see anything above you you
like really got a lean forward and then
also because it's so low getting in and
out of the car is kind of funny it's a
probably a legit challenge for a lot of
people the doors of course go up instead
of out so you can't really use them as
handles to hold on to to get in and out
otherwise we'll just close them on
yourself so you end up doing this kind
of a shimmy to get in and out it's
pretty great there's a button in the
cockpit that's what I'll call it a
cockpit to switch between driving modes
strata which is like street driving then
sport and then Corsa which is basically
race mode it's mean as hell and then ego
mode is kind of your own custom cocktail
of the settings mixed between them all
the gauge cluster is super sexy
changes with the driving modes and has
me feeling kind of like a fighter pilot
as soon as I sit in the driver's seat
and I got to say even though this car
came out in 2018 it is nice to see a
screen without a notch on it it has a
surprisingly tight corner and radius
because the back wheels actually turn a
little bit to move tighter and of course
just driving generally is insane
huge wheels huge grip huge brakes and
huge power and now I come to think of it
huge sound it's louder than you think
pretty much all the time
it's just sensory overload as soon as
you're holding the steering wheel I'd
say it's kind of the opposite of a Tesla
and lastly actually one of the most
interesting facts is the 2018
Lamborghini Aventador s does not have
Android auto that's actually one of the
reasons I first caught my eye first got
on our radar was because we thought it
had Android auto there was headlines
about it I got a lot of hype for it
there were some people saying oh this is
the most expensive car with Android auto
we opened it up on our phone we plugged
it in we tried it as far as we could
tell this car does not have Android auto
if it does I couldn't find it and nobody
who works at Lamborghini who worked with
us on this video could find it as far as
we know it could get it over a software
update which these cars do get which is
really interesting but as of today the
headlines are wrong the Aventador just
has car play and it's actually not even
on Apple's list of cars that officially
support car play if you look it up
there's another older Lamborghini model
listed but not this one so it's just
kind of off the grid go figure but there
you have it if you are if you're looking
for a recommendation from me on whether
or not to buy this car I'm not quite
very yet obviously I just spent a day
and a half with the car but it was a lot
of fun so shout out to Lamborghini for
the car and for making this all happen
and for reaching out after my tweet to
get this together shout out to the
dealership in Palm Beach for hosting and
showing us around and shout out to Casey
nice tat for being the area photographer
for this video I'll link his channel
below and he also dropped a video a
little bit of behind the scenes and
shout out to you for watching Doc's you
guys the next one peace